just as a
tiny tangent we mentioned edward whitten
and he
in a bunch of walks of life for me as an
outsider comes up as a person who is uh
widely considered as like one of the
most brilliant people in the history of
physics
just as a powerhouse uh of a human
like the uh the exceptional places that
a human mind can rise to
yes uh you've gotten a chance to work
with him what's he like
yes more than that he was my advisor uh
phd advisor so i got to know him very
well and i benefited from his insights
in fact
what you say about him is accurate he is
he's not only brilliant but you know he
is
he's also multifaceted in terms of the
impact he has had in not only physics
but also in mathematics
you know he's got in the fields medal
because of his work in mathematics and
rightly so you know he has used his
knowledge of physics in a way which
impacted
deep ideas in modern mathematics and
that's an example of
of the power of of these ideas in modern
high energy physics and string theory
that
the applicability of it to to modern
mathematics so
he's uh he's quite uh exceptional
individual we don't we don't come across
such people a lot in history
so i think yes indeed he's one of the
rare figures in this history of
the subject he has had great impact on a
lot of aspects of not just string theory
a lot of different areas in physics
and also yes in mathematics as well so i
think what you said about him is
accurate
i had the pleasure of interacting with
him as a student and and later on as
colleagues
writing papers together and so on what
impact do you have on your life like
what have you learned from him if you
were to look at the trajectory of your
mind of the way you approached science
and physics and mathematics
how did he uh perturb that trajectory
yes
he did actually so i can explain because
when i was a student i i
had the biggest impact by him uh clearly
as a grad student at princeton so i
think
uh that was a time where i was a little
bit confused
about the relation between math and
physics i got a double major in
mathematics and physics at mit
and because i really enjoyed both and i
write the elegance and the rigor of
mathematics
and i like the power of ideas and
physics and its applicability to reality
and what it teaches about
the real world around us but i saw this
tension between
rigorous thinking in mathematics and
lack thereof in physics and this
troubled me to no end i was troubled by
that
so i was at crossroads when i decided to
go to graduate school in physics because
i did not like some of the lack of
rigors i was seeing in physics
on the other hand to me mathematics even
though it was rigorous something it
it sometimes were i didn't see the point
of it in other words
when i see when i see you know the math
theorem by itself could be beautiful but
i really wanted more than that i want to
say okay what does
it teach us about something else
something more than just math
so i wasn't i wasn't that enamored with
just math but physics was a little bit
bothersome nevertheless i decided to go
to physics and i decided to go to
princeton
and i started working with edward
whitten as my thesis advisor
and um at that time i was trying to
put physics in rigorous mathematical
terms i took one of field theory
i tried to make rigorous out of it and
so on and
no matter how hard i was trying i was
not being able to do that
and i was falling behind from my classes
i was not learning
much physics and i was not making it
rigorous and to me
it was this dichotomy between math and
physics what am i doing i like math but
this is not
exactly there comes ed within as my
advisor and i see him in action
thinking about math and physics
he was amazing in math he knew all about
the math it was no problem with him
but he thought about physics in a way
which did not
find this tension between the two
it was much more harmonious for him he
would draw the feynman diagrams but he
wouldn't
view it as a formalism he was viewed oh
yeah the particle goes over there and
this is what's going on and
so wait you're thinking really is this
particle this virtual this is really
electron going there right yeah yeah
it's not
it's not the formula no no
you just feel like the electron you're
moving with this guy and do that and so
on and you're thinking invariantly about
physics or the way he thought about
relativity like you know i was thinking
about you know this momentum says
he was thinking invariantly about
physics just like the way you think
about invariant concepts in relativity
which don't depend on the frame of
reference
he was thinking about the physics in in
variant ways that
the way that doesn't gives you a bigger
perspective so
this gradually helped me appreciate that
interconnections between ideas and
physics replaces
mathematical rigor that the different
facets
reinforce each other you say oh i cannot
rigorously define what i mean by this
but this thing
connects with this other physics i have
seen and this other thing and they
together form
an elegant story and that replaced for
me what i
believed as a solidness which i found in
math as a rigor
it was solid i found that replaced the
rigor and solidness in physics so i
found
okay that's the way you can hang on to
it is not wishy-washy it's not like
somebody is just not being able to prove
it just making up a story
it was more than that and it was no
tension with mathematics
in fact mathematics was helping it like
friends
and so much more harmonious and gives
insights to physics
so that's i think one of the main things
i learned from interactions with written
and i think that now perhaps i have
taken
that to a far extreme maybe he wouldn't
go this far as i have namely
i use physics to define new mathematics
in a way which would be far
less rigorous than a physicist might
necessarily believe because i take the
physical intuition
perhaps literally in many ways that
could teach us about so now i've gained
so much confidence
in physical intuition that i make bold
statements that sometimes you know
takes math math friends off guard
so an example of it is mirror symmetry
so
so we were studying these compactivation
of string string geometries this is
after my phd now i've
by the time i've come to harvard we're
studying these aspects of string
compactification on these
complicated manifolds six-dimensional
spaces called clavial manifolds
very complicated and i noticed
with a couple other colleagues that
there was a symmetry
in physics suggested between different
calabias suggested that
you couldn't actually compute the euler
characteristic of a calabia or the
characteristic is
counting the number of points minus the
number of edges plus the number of faces
minus
so you can count the alternating
sequence of properties of the space
which is the topological property of a
space
so holy cakes of the calabia was a
property of the space and so
we noticed that from the physics
formalism if string moves in a columbia
you cannot distinguish we cannot compute
the euler characteristic you can only
compute the absolute value of it
now this bothered us because how could
you not compute the actual sign
unless the both sides were the same
so i conjectured maybe for every calabia
with the other characteristics positive
there's one with negative
i told this to my colleague yao who was
whose namesake is
that i'm making this conjecture is it
possible that for every calabia there's
one with the opposite other
characteristic
sounds not reasonable i said why i said
well we know more
claudia's with negative other characters
than positive
i said but physics says we cannot
distinguish them at least i don't see
how
so we conjectured that for every calabia
with one side there's the other one
despite the mathematical evidence
despite the mathematical evidence
despite the expert telling us this is
not the right idea
if a few years later this symmetric
mirror symmetry between the
sign with the opposite sign was later
confirmed by mathematicians
so this is actually the opposite view
that is physics is so sure about it
that you're going against the
mathematical wisdom telling them they
better look for it
so taking the uh the the physical
intuition literally
and then having that drive the
mathematics exactly and by now we are so
confident about
many such examples that has affected
modern mathematics
in ways like this that we are much more
confident about
our understanding of what string
theories these are another aspects
other aspects of why we feel string
theory is correct it's doing these kind
of things
you